[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तू जो वेलकम तू
रिटर्न ऑफ दिस फ्री कैप्शन कोर्स
एक बार आप लोग मुझे बता दीजिए की आप सबको
मेरी आवाज ए रही है
सबको
मी टॉपिक
ओके वेरी गुड ठीक है तो
मुझे यह बताइए
तो अगेन फिर से मैं बता देता बता देता हूं
की जैसे ही क्लास खत्म हो जाएगी हमारी
आजकल लास्ट आज का जो क्लास सेंड हो जाएगा
डेट और तो आपको क्या करना है सिंपली हमारे
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में हमारा लिंकडइन
पेज है
वापस आपको क्या करना है की हमारे
वेब पेज पर जाना है
जहां पर हमारा डिफरेंस सिक्योरिटी का वेब
पेज है वहां पर क्या करना है की वहां पर
जैसे तेजी क्लास और हो जाएगी तो आपको डेट
और का क्लास अपडेट हो जाएगा तो प्लीज आप
लोग चाहेगा आप रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन देखिए चाहे
आप लाइव सेशन देखिए जैसे आपको सेशन आप ओवर
कर लेते हो आप एक बार वीडियो को देख लेते
तो प्लीज आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है आपको
जैसा भी लगा अच्छा लगा या बड़ा लगा तो
वहां पर लाइक किया अनलाइक या कमेंट कीजिए
तो प्लीज को तू हिल
सेशन को लाइक कर सकते हैं
आप लोगों को क्या समझ में आया क्या नहीं
आया आप लोग क्या लगता की ट्रेनिंग
बता सकते हैं
तो आज का मां टॉपिक कंटिन्यू सिक्योरिटी
से थोड़ी सी कुछ हमने जो लास्ट क्लास में
पढ़ा था वो स्टैंडर्ड परमीशंस के बड़े में
पढ़ा था लेकिन जो आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं वो
हमारे रिलेटेड तो है
एडवांस परमिशन
फाइल सिक्योरिटी तो हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं
जिनको आना था वो ए गए
तो चलो एक बार मैं
जोमिन कर देता हूं जो में जो में ओके ओके
टाइप्स ऑफ एडवांस
फाइल परमीशंस फॉर्मेशन
इसमें सबसे पहले
फर्स्ट है
वह है
सेठ जी आई दी सेट जी आई दी चाट जी आइडिया
फाइल परमीशंस ओके तो बात करते हैं अब
नेक्स्ट इनके बड़े में समझते हैं विद
प्रैक्टिकल समझते हैं तो सबसे पहले हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं जो हमारी फर्स्ट
परमीशंस है कौन सी है
इसके बड़े में डिस्कस करने वाले हैं सबसे
पहले
हम सेट करते हैं
तो उसके अंदर जो भी फाइल्स है
उसके अलावा कोई भी उसे फाइल को डिलीट नहीं
कर सकता कोई भी अगर यूजर्स डिलीट नहीं कर
सकते हैं
देखो पर एग्जांपल में एक एग्जांपल लेट हूं
छोटा सा नेगेटिव देता हूं
की किसी कंपनी में नहीं एक प्रोजेक्ट चल
रहा था और उसे प्रोजेक्ट में
20 30 लोग 20 लॉजेस का एग्जाम लेते हैं 20
लोग हैं वो कम कर रहे हैं
तो प्रोजेक्ट का क्या है आम डायरेक्टर है
कोई भी प्रोजेक्ट को नाम दिया आम
डायरेक्टरी है उनको सर कम उधर ही करना है
क्योंकि जो उनका मैनेजर है जो बस है वह
उधर ही है और वो जितने भी कम कर रहे हैं
उनका कम स्टेटस चेक करने के लिए वह हर एक
फाइल को ओपन करके देखा है
उसके बाद क्या है
कुछ लोग ऐसे होंगे जिनको एक दूसरे से
प्रॉब्लम होगी एक दूसरे से प्रॉब्लम होगी
किसी ने अच्छा प्रोजेक्ट बना दिया हुआ
किसी ने अच्छी रिपोर्ट बना दी होगी किसी
ने अच्छी रिपोर्ट नहीं बना पाया होगा अब
जो अच्छी रिपोर्ट नहीं बनाया उसने क्या
किया
उसे दूसरे यूजर की फाइल्स को ओपन करके
देखा
यह इसने यह रिपोर्ट बनाई है अब उसको
प्रॉब्लम थी उसने क्या का दिया उसे फाइल
को डिलीट कर दिया उसे फाइल को डिलीट कर
दिया
उसने अपनी मशीन को ऑन किया उसने देखा नहीं
तो फाइल है ही नहीं उसने क्या किया उसने
किसी और दूसरी फाइल को डिलीट कर दिया अब
यह साड़ी चीज प्रॉब्लम चल रही थी
कोई भी एक यूजर किसी दूसरे युद्ध की फाइल
को डिलीट ना कर पे इसका एक सॉल्यूशन हमें
निकालना था तो इस सॉल्यूशन को निकालना के
लिए
क्या किया
जो प्रोजेक्ट चल रहा था जिसमें
20 लोग कम कर रहे थे अगर उसे प्रोजेक्ट
कर दिया तो उसका मतलब यह है की
वे 20 लोग जो प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर कम कर रहे
हैं उसे प्रोजेक्ट मेंबर्स हैं वह अपने
अपने फाइल्स में कम करते हैं और कम करने
के बाद उसने क्या उन्होंने फाइल को क्लोज
करती है
बट क्या है की एक यूजर दूसरी यूजर्स की
फाइल को डिलीट नहीं कर सकता
है मतलब जी फाइल का जो फाइल ओनर है उसको
वही डिलीट कर सकता है
एड मैंने यूजर एड किया और न्यू
करो दी ए एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स आईटी इंटर डी
ए एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स डिप्लोनिक्स इसका
पासवर्ड मैंने रखा नेक्स्ट मैंने ए को उसे
क्रिएट किया जिसका नाम था यूजर तू आईटी
इंटर किया ये जो तू दस नोट ओके
मैं यूजर एड कर रहा हूं
और मैंने क्या किया
इंटर उसके लिए मैं पासवर्ड डिपेंड
कियरोनिक्स दी ए एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स मैंने
ये पासवर्ड के ऊपर सेट कर दिया तो तीनों
यूजेस का पासवर्ड क्या है
अब मैंने क्या किया मौला अपने रूट
पार्टीशन में मैं क्या करता हूं एक बार
सीडी होम मेड चला जाता हूं ओके ओके
कंट्रोल
यो में चला जाता हूं बैलेंस करता हूं अब
मैंने यहां पर क्या किया
इट्स ओके चलेगा
मैं इसके ऊपर पहले से परमिशन चेक कर लेट
हूं
77 और जो डायरेक्टरी
ओम आम इसको मैं फूल परवेज दे दिया अब
मैंने क्या किया मैं मैंने क्या किया मैं
स्विच करता हूं मैंने स किया
परमानेंटली यूजर वन के अंदर
क्या किया
ऑपरेटर यूजर वन
डॉट टी एक्स टी के नाम से फाइल क्रिएट
के नाम से एक फाइल क्रिएट हो राखी है अगर
इसके अंदर का डाटा हम रीड करते हैं
तो इसके अंदर आपको एक कैलेंडर देखने को
मिलेगा ओके ये क्या किया है यूजर वन ने एक
फाइल डिलीट कर दी अब मैं इसे बाहर ए जाता
हूं यूजर वन से मैं स्विच करता हूं यूजर
तू के अंदर
यूजर तू के अंदर में स्विच किया अब मैं
पीडी करके दिखता हूं अभी मैं रूट के अंदर
तो शिरडी करता हूं
जिसके अंदर आपको मिल रही है अगर मैं कैट
करता हूं उसके अंदर डाटा मैं देख सकता हूं
उसने क्या कर दिया इसको डिलीट कर दिया
हालांकि किसने
इसने अगर मैं इसको एक कम कर डिलीट करने से
पहले करके दिखा देता हूं आपको देखने को
मिलेगा इसका जो फाइल ओनर है वह यूजर वन है
और डिलीट करने वाला कौन है अगर वो मी करके
दिखता हूं मैं आपको तो ये यूज्ड तू है तो
अब इसमें क्या-क्या रिमूव किया और
यूजर वन डॉट टी एक्स टी को ये क्या कर रहा
था इसने रिमूव कर दिया डीएक्सट
अभी क्या कर रिमूव करना है और ओके यस
अब इसमें इसको रिमूव कर दिया मैं एलएस
करता हूं तो यहां पर क्या है यूजर वन तू
टेक्स्ट तू फाइल आपको देखने को नहीं मिलती
अब यहां पर सेट नहीं है इसलिए ऐसी
प्रॉब्लम होगी
प्लस
टी उसके बाद
इसके ऊपर मैंने क्या है
आपको अब आपको यहां देखने को मिलेगा
यहां पर आपको टी मिल जाएगा इसका मतलब क्या
है
एक्स की जगह देखने को मिल रहा है जहां पर
एग्जीक्यूट परमीशंस रहती है एक चीज यहां
पर ध्यान रखना अगर यहां पर स्मॉल टी आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है इसका मतलब है की जो
ये सेट है
अगर आपको यहां पर कैपिटल टी देखने को
मिलता है तो इसका मतलब क्या है की वेबसाइट
करता हूं
पीडी करता हूं
अब इसके अंदर
पीडी
करता हूं तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं
और
यूजर वन डॉट टेक्स्ट के नाम से फिर से
क्रेडिट कर देता हूं
आपको देखने को मिलेगा
सेट है तो आप इसकी फाइल को डिलीट नहीं कर
सकते ठीक है क्या बोलती है की
फाइल का फाइल को जिसने एडिट किया है उसे
फाइल का जो ओनर है वही उसको क्या कर सकता
है उसको डिलीट कर सकता है उसके अलावा उसको
कोई भी डिलीट नहीं कर सकता जो आपके सामने
एक लाइव एग्जांपल है तो ये है स्टिकी बीट
आपकी अगर आपको रिमूव करना है वो कैसे
रिमूव कर सकते हैं एक बार मैं आउट कर दे
आउट हो जाता हूं अगर आपको एक चीज दूसरे
तरीके से अगर स्टिकी बीट को आपको ऑप्टिकल
मेथड से सेट करना तो उसके लिए आपको है
ऑलरेडी सेट है
देखने को मिली थी पैसे यहां पर भी क्या है
ये आपका एडवांस परमिशन को सेट करने के लिए
किया जाता है इसलिए वन का मतलब आप क्या है
अगर आपको रिमूव करना है
अब मैं एलर्जी करके दिखता हूं तो आपको
देखने मिल रहा है
अगर मैं आपको एड करके दिखाऊं आप फिर से एक
भी तरीका है एक तो ये है एड करने का तरीका
जिसे मैंने एड कर दिया ल एस दी करके दिखा
दिया स्टिकी बीट सेट होगी अब मैं क्या
करता हूं मैं अगर एक तरीका है रिमूव करने
का वो है क मोड उसके बाद माइंस टी और
अगर आपको पहले
ये दो तीन तरीके से सिक्किम को रिमूव करने
का
अब बात करते हैं
जो नेक्स्ट है
उसकी बात करते हैं हम
के बड़े में
सीआईडी
एचडी
क्या होता है
की अगर
हम किसी अगर हम किसी डायरेक्टर पर
एसजीआईडी सेट करते हैं तो इसका मतलब वो
मेक सर करता है या वह मिक्सर करती है की
उसके अंदर जितने भी फाइल्स किया
डायरेक्टरी होगी उन सरों का जो ग्रुप ओनर
होगा आप सबको पता है ग्रुप ओनर कौन होता
है
पैंड रिमूव के डायरेक्टर
[संगीत]
हूं
जिसका नाम था अभी एक मैं प्रोजेक्ट पे कम
कर रहे हैं
प्रोजेक्ट प्रोजेक्ट
यह प्रोजेक्ट किया
7 साइन परमिशन 77 और किसके ऊपर
प्रोजेक्ट
95 के ऊपर अब एलएस हाईपॉट लड करके देख रहे
हैं इसके परमिशन मेरी इस फूल परमिशन मैंने
क्या कहा था प्रोजेक्ट 99 को दे दिया अब
क्या जो मेरे ग्रुप है ग्रुप मैंने एड
किया था ना तब मैं क्या कर देता हूं जो
मेरे यूजर मोड कर देता हूं आईफोन ए आईफोन
कैपिटल जी अब ग्रुप का नाम क्या है मेरा
ग्रुप का नाम है जो एड किया था वो था
एमकेडी है जो किया था मैंने
पूछा
अब हम क्या करते हैं
इसका चेंज होना नॉर्मल रोटी रखना
वो है प्रोजेक्ट रखना पी और के आई सी टी
प्रोजेक्ट रख दिया किसका प्रोजेक्ट 90 का
ये 10 का अब मैं क्या करता हूं एलएस लड
करके दिखता हूं आपको देखने को मिलेगा 90
यहां पर क्या प्रोजेक्ट नंबर आपको एक-एक
ग्रुप ओनर देखने को मिल रहा है अब हम क्या
करते हैं अब हम चाहते हैं की
जितनी भी फाइल चाहिए सब डायरेक्टर इसके
अंदर क्रिएट हो उनका जो ग्रुप है वो बाय
डिफॉल्टर यह प्रोजेक्ट ही होना चाहिए
प्रोजेक्ट ही होना चाहिए अब ऐसा नहीं ऐसा
क्यों करना था तो पर एग्जांपल हम किसी
प्रोजेक्ट पे कम कर रहे हैं उसके बहुत
सारे मेंबर्स हैं जैसे अभी मेंबर्स मेरे
हैं वो उसे प्रोजेक्ट में कम कर रहे हैं
अब वो चाहते हैं की बाय रिपोर्ट में जितने
भी फाइल स्टेट हो उनका जो ग्रुप ओनर ऑफ
प्रोजेक्ट की बात की लोग भी उसके अंदर की
फाइल को रीड कर पे इसलिए उसके अंदर की
परमिशन के हिसाब से
क्या करोगे आप क्या करोगे
बार-बार आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा उसका ग्रुप
होना चेंज करना पड़ेगा लेकिन ऐसा ना करने
की वजह आप क्या कर सकते हो इसके ऊपर
सेट कर सकते हैं
अपना पीडी करके दिखा रहा हूं आपको टीएनपी
के अंदर हमें सीडी करता हूं उसके बाद
टीएमटी के अंदर भी मैं किसके अंदर जाता
हूं
प्रोजेक्ट 90 के अंदर प्रो
90 के अंदर
पीडी करके दिखाओ
इसके अंदर कुछ नहीं है हमने यहां पर क्या
किया फाइल डिलीट कर रहा हूं एक फाइल ग्रिड
कर रहा हूं टी ओ यू सी ल टच
टेस्ट
file.in
अब यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल रहा हो इसका
जो फाइल है और इसका जो यूजर
अब क्या इसको क्या चाहिए था प्रोजेक्ट ही
इसका ग्रुप होना चाहिए था जो प्रोजेक्ट है
ये इसका ग्रुप होना चाहिए
अगर ये इसका मेंबर है एडरवाइज नहीं तो
यहां पर ट्रिक अब तक क्या है एसजीआईडी सेट
नहीं है इसलिए क्या है की यह भाई डिफॉल्ट
यह हुआ नहीं अब मैं क्या करता हूं एग्जिट
कर देता हूं और एसजीआईडी शेर करके दिखता
हूं तो क मोड किया है मैंने और मैं क्या
करता हूं सीजी डेबिट सेट करने के लिए मैं
क्या करता हूं जी ग्रुप के ग्रुप के ऊपर
लगती है ये एसजीआईडी प्लस
सीजी आईडी भी उसके बाद इसके ऊपर सेट करना
चाहता हूं प्रोजेक्ट 90 के ऊपर
एलईडी करके देखोगे तो आपको यहां पर देखने
को मिलेगा रु और एस ये जो हाईलाइट किया है
एक्स की जगह एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन आपको एस
देखने को मिलता है बेसिकली इसका मतलब क्या
है की अब इस जो डायरेक्ट ये जो डायरेक्टली
है इसके ऊपर क्या सेट है आपकी
सेट है और अगर कैपिटल एस देखने को मिलेगा
तो ये विदाउट एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन है स्मॉल
आगे देखने को मिलेगा
परमिशन आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
टच
और अब क्या मोबाइल का नाम बताओ
पीरियड करोगे जैसे की अगर मैं एग्जिट करता
हूं और मैंने क्या किया मैं स्विच करता
हूं यूजर वन तू के अंदर और मैं क्या करता
हूं सीडी
सेंटर
करता हूं
यह तुम्हारा
कैसे होगा रिमूव करने के लिए
उसके बाद क्या करना प्रोजेक्ट प्रोजेक्ट
90 अब एल्डर आईटी करके देखो यहां से आपके
बेटा आपको क्या हो जाएगी रिमूव हो जाएगी
ये रिमूव का तरीका नेक्स्ट मैं आपको बताता
हूं बात कर रहे थे हम थर्ड नंबर पे
बात कर रहे हैं 2 अब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
बात कर रहा हूं
अब ये क्या होता है
नॉर्मल यूजर को रेड लाइट है
तो कैसे पॉसिबल है
लेकिन फिर भी तो हम जैसे कर सकता है
रुस यहां पर पहले से ही क्या सेट है एस
यूआईडी
अब इसका मतलब
बाइनरी फाइल है जिसकी हेल्प करते
यह इसका बात है
इसलिए यहां पर आपको एस यूआईडी देखने को
मिलती है क्योंकि देखो इसका में यूजर में
होना तो क्या रूट है लेकिन सम टाइम्स क्या
होता है पार्ट डी कमांड को आप क्या कर
पाते हो
नॉर्मल यूजर से भी फायर कर पाते हो ठीक है
आप बोलोगे
लेकिन आप सुडोकू देखना अगर छोड़ो जो कमांड
है उससे भी एस यू आईडी भी सेट है मतलब एस
यू आईडी बीट का मतलब क्या है की वो किसी
कमांड को ऐसे एग्जीक्यूट करती है या जिसके
ऊपर सेट है वो किसी भी फाइल को ऐसे
एग्जीक्यूट करती है जैसे उसको उसके ही में
ओनर ने उसको क्या किया हो एग्जीक्यूट
करवाया हो पर एग्जांपल आपके सामने रूट है
तो इसको रूट नहीं ऐसे उसको एग्जीक्यूट
करवाती है ये हा यूआइडीएआइ का
मतलब है
डी कमांड
करता हूं और कंट्रोल
करना यार
क्लियर है ना ओके ओके ओके
कॉन्सेप्ट था मैंने आप लास्ट दे नाइन से
स्टार्ट किया था और डेट में आपको और कर
दिया यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट कॉन्सेप्ट था
क्योंकि एस यूआईडी एसजीआईडी
का लोगो पता नहीं राहत इसके बेस पे आपका
रिलेशन होता है ओके तो
आपको समझ में ए गया की स्टैंडर्ड और
एडवांस परमीशंस का तो एक बार मुझे यह
कमेंट आउट कर दीजिए की आप लोगों को यह समझ
में आया या नहीं आया की टिकट क्या होता है
बढ़ते हैं तेरे
यह कॉन्सेप्ट हमारा फाइल सिक्योरिटी
गार्डन कंप्लीट हो गया
कमांड उसे कर लेते हैं उसके बड़े में जान
लेते हैं इट्स वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड जो
अभी आपके सामने मैंने उसे किया फाइंड
कमांड इसके बड़े में जानते हैं की कैसे कम
करती है और आपको इसकी नॉलेज हनी बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है चाहे आप कुछ भी करो आपको
ये जो कमांड्स होती है जो मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं उनकी नॉलेज आपको बहुत ही ज्यादा
जरूरी है सो अब क्या की इंटरेस्ट हो रहा
होगा
तो इंटरेस्ट से हमने क्या किया कुछ अपने
कॉन्सेप्ट को क्लियर कर लिया फिर से कुछ
समाज तो बीच-बीच में सीखनी पड़ेगी तो आज
जो कमांड हम सीखने वाले हैं
फाइंड कमांड के बड़े में सीखने वाले हैं
अपने सिस्टम
है की आपके पूरे फाइल सिस्टम में पूरे
फाइल सिस्टम कहानी पर भी कोई भी कमांड
सर्च कर सकते हैं कोई भी फाइल सर्च कर
सकते सॉरी कोई भी फाइल कमांड
के बेस पर कुछ भी सर्च कर सकते हैं
फाइंड
आउट मतलब मैं करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी में
क्या कर सकते हैं
मतलब क्या नाम है जिसको आप सर्च करना
चाहते हैं
उसके बाद मुझे नो आइडिया तो मैंने स्टार
उसे कर लिया
जो इसके बाद
देखिए इसने बता दिया की आपकी विद लोकेशन
डॉट टेक्सटाइल मार्केट
के अंदर ओके अब मैं क्या कर सकता हूं टाइप
भी दे सकता हूं ओनली पर्टिकुलर फाइल सर्च
करना चाहता हूं ना की डायरेक्ट दे दो ओके
फाइल उसके बाद आप क्या कर रहे हो आईफोन
नाम नाम क्या रहेगा उसका ना
उसका नाम रहेगा पर एग्जांपल
ओके इसके साथ अभी कम नहीं कर रहा
हूं मैंने क्या किया ठीक है मैं अभी टेस्ट
करना चाहता हूं की कहां पर है वो फाइल
सिस्टम है टेक्स्ट फाइबर डीएक्सट
अब इसमें क्या है इसको शो कर दिया बट इसको
पहले भी कम करना चाहिए था इसको बट वाइस
नोट वर्किंग
पर एग्जांपल
कहां पर है पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन क्या है तो
टेस्ट 1.3xt अंदर गया अब इसमें सर्च कर
दिया बट इसने क्या कैपिटल टी वाले को शो
नहीं किया क्यों लेने से क्या सेंसेटिव है
अगर आप क्या करना चाहते हो कैसे सेंसेटिव
को क्या करना चाहते हो बाईपास करना चाहते
हो आप कहते हैं कैसे इन सेंसेटिव बनाना
चाहते हो तो क्या करोगे फाइंड कमांड उसके
बाद कर उसके बाद आपको क्या है करंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
टाइप उसके बाद हाय फोन
नाम रहेगा
लगाना पड़ेगा
दोनों को आपकी स्क्रीन पर शो कर दिया ये
कैपिटल टी फर्स्ट स्मॉल टी दोनों को स्पिन
के ऊपर इसमें क्या कर दिया शो कर दिया अब
बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट बढ़ते हैं अगर मुझे
ओनली डायरेक्टली को ही सर्च करना है ओनली
डायरेक्टली को ही सब्सक्राइब के साथ बताता
था ओनली डायरेक्टली कोई भी सर्च करें तो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं ओके मैंने क्या किया
एक बार मैं सीडी करता हूं रोड के अंदर और
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं यहां अंदर मैं क्या
करता हूं एक बार एम के दी आई या
एमपी के अंदर
[संगीत]
क्या करना है
मुझे नहीं पता तो कहां पर है
नाम रखना चाहता हूं
आईफोन
नाम
को सब्सक्राइब
ओपन नाम ओके 5.5
एम पी के अंदर
अगर मैं ऐसा चाहता हूं तो ऐसे भी कर सकता
था मैं चाहता हूं
तो यह भी कर सकता हूं आई के साथ मतलब
सीडी करता हूं फाइंड किया मैंने और रोड
पार्टीशन आईफोन फूल पार्टीशन करता हूं
बेस्ट स्टॉक
आईटी इंटर अभी भी ये कम कर रहा है
तो इस तरीके से आप किसी भी फाइल को किसी
भी डायरेक्टरी को किसी एक्सटेंशन के साथ
मल्टीपल जब फाइल लेकिन आपको कुछ कीवर्ड
याद है उसके हिसाब से आप क्या कर सकते हो
अपना सर्च ऑपरेशन फाइंड ऑपरेशन कर सकते हो
सर्च कर सकते हो की आपके पूरे फाइल सिस्टम
के अंदर आईटी इस वेरी फास्ट बहुत वीकली कम
कर रहा है पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है
किसी भी परमीशंस के बेस पर मैं क्या कहना
चाहता हूं की सर्च करना चाहता हूं अभी मैं
कर सकता हूं तो मैं फाइंड किया फूल रूट के
अंदर सब्सक्राइब
774 आईफोन प्रिंट कर दीजिए
इसके ऊपर क्या है 7 7 परमीशंस है आपको
देखने को मिल रही है
एवरीथिंग ओके
एक और अब इतना पता चल गया
कुछ भी कर सकते हैं अगर मैं चाहता हूं की
नहीं मैं फाइंड करना चाहता हूं
नोट इस परमिशन को छोड़कर बाकी साड़ी
परमिशन
077 जो परमीशंस है इनको छोड़कर छोड़ के
बाकी सब को क्या करना चाहता हूं मैं
प्रिंट करना चाहता हूं पी आर आई एन टी
प्रिंट सिस्टम
बहुत ही फास्ट कम करता है यार बहुत फास्ट
करके दिखा दिया
सर्च करना है अगर आप ग्रुप आई दी के बेस
की बेस पे भी सर्च कर सकते हो ग्रुप आईडी
के बेस पे भी आपको पता है फर्स्ट वाइस
सिटी की ब्यूटीफुल पीछे परमिशन कुछ भी आप
रख सकते हैं अब मैं आपको बताता हूं अगर
पार्टी के बेस पे अगर मैं दिखाऊं आपको तो
ठीक है पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया एक
फाइल है मेरे पास मैंने
टी ओ यू सी टच किया हैप्पी डॉट टी एक्स टी
डेंटल सी हा मोड गेम मैंने उसके ऊपर तू
सिक्स फोर फोर परमीशंस को रखा मैंने
ओके
देखने को मिलेगा
फाइंड करना चाहता हूं
परमीशंस के बेस पे भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं पट्टी का फाइल को फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्ट देखो फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हैं अब सबसे मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
सीखने जा रहा हूं आपको मैं अगर आप किसी
पार्टिकल फाइल को फाइल की परमिशन को फाइंड
करके चेंज करना चाहते हैं आप मैंने क्या
किया
2644 इस फाइल को परमीशंस है मैं क्या
चाहता हूं की मैं इसकी परमीशंस को भी चैन
चेंज करना चाहता हूं अभी से टाइम कैसे अभी
विद डी हेल्प ऑफ फाइंड कमांड वो हम कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि मैंने उसको फाइंड आउट भी
किया और मैं अपने हिसाब से उसके ऊपर जो
चेंज अप्लाई करना चाहता हूं वो कर सकता
हूं
ऐसा नहीं है की आपने अभी फाइंड किया उसके
बाद करोगे उसकी परमिशन चेंज करोगे ऐसा दो
तीन स्टेप में करने की बजे हम एक स्टेप
में कर सकते हैं कैसे मैंने क्या किया
फाइंड
आपके सामने
भी दे सकते हो उसके बाद क्या करोगे मैंने
फायर करना चाहते हैं इस पर्टिकुलर जो आपको
फाइल जितनी भी फाइल्स मिलेगी इस परमिशन के
साथ तू सिक्स फोर फोर
उनको जो प्रिंट करोगे उसके ऊपर जो जो
कमांड फायर करना था पर एग्जांपल मैं क मोड
फाइल करना चाहता है क मोड परमिशन रखना
चाहता हूं तू 77 ये परमेश्वर रखना चाहता
हूं इसके ऊपर उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है
ये सिंटेक्स का पहले ब्रिक्स ओपन क्लोज
उसके बाद फॉरवर्ड एसएलएक्स पोस्ट के बाद
सेमी कलर ये इसका सिंटेक्स रहेगा ये एक्स
सी एग्जीक्यूट करना है यहां पर आपको कमांड
का नाम लिखना है और लास्ट में आपको करली
ब्रैकेट ओपन और क्लोज उसके बाद स्लैश और
सेमीफाइनल आपको रखना ही रखना है इंटर कर
दिया मैंने मिसिंग एल्गोरिथम ए एक्स ए
अमेजिंग
ओके
व्हाट इसे डी मीनिंग
[संगीत]
ओके इट्स ओके प्रॉब्लम
जिसकी परमिशन 266 परमीशंस है अब मैं क्या
करता था उसकी परमिशन चेंज करना चाहता हूं
जितनी भी फाइल्स मिलेंगे पर क्या अप्लाई
करना चाहता हूं तू ट्रिपल सेवन परमीशंस
अप्लाई करना चाहता हूं एसजीआईडी ओके तो हम
कर सकते हैं उसके बाद में एक्स के बाद
क्या करना है एक्सिस मतलब एग्जीक्यूट करो
आई इसके अंदर क्या कमांड लिखोगे यहां पर
आपको स्पेस सेपरेटेड रखना मैं वहां एक
मिस्टेक कर रहा हूं ये और ये ओपन कर लीजिए
और क्लोज कर लीजिए आपको फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस
उसके बाद ये अब आपको मैं अगर दिखता हूं
एलएस आईफोन ल करके दिखता हूं किसको
सिक्स वाले परमिशन स्वामी हैप्पी डर्टी
परमिशन चेंज होगी
फाइंड कमांड के साथ किसी भी फाइल को अब
ढूंढ भी सकते हो और उसके ऊपर जो कमांड
फुर्थर कमांड फायर करना चाहते हो उन
फाइल्स के साथ रिजल्ट के साथ हो फरदर
कमांड आप फायर कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ
वन ऑप्शन एक्स एग्जीक्यूट ऑप्शंस के साथ
तो
नेक्स्ट कमांड के बड़े में अगर मैं ये
देखना चाहता हूं अगर मैं लिस्ट आउट करना
चाहता हूं की जो मेरे स्लेस्ट डायरेक्टरी
है एमपी डायरेक्टर भी है फाइंड करना चाहता
हूं मैं
डायरेक्टर के अंदर ये फाइंड आउट करना
चाहता हूं की एम्टी फाइल कितनी है मत फाइल
फाइंड आउट करना था उसके लिए होता है
वो भी आप देख सकते हैं सिंपली
दी करके
इसके अंदर पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
अगर मैं पूरे फाइल सिस्टम में देखना चाहता
हूं तो वो भी देख सकता हूं फाइंड
फूल रूट पार्टीशन उसके बाद क्या जाता है
फाइल देखना चाहता हूं जो एम्टी हिफिन एक
पी टी ए एमपी 800
मत है खाली है देखिए वो ज्यादा बड़ी लिस्ट
है
डॉट
पोर्नस है
व्यू
देखने को मिल रही होगी अगर आप क्या करते
किसी पर्टिकुलर ओनर की फाइल को सर्च करना
चाहते हैं वो भी हम कर सकते हैं कैसे पर
एग्जांपल मैं फाइंड करना चाहता हूं
करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी में आईफोन उर्स
उसके लिए आप उसे करोगे फ्लैग यू एस सी आर
यूजर उसके बाद किस यूजर के नाम से सर्च
करना चाहता हूं
इस वेरी बिगेस्ट यार
बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी लिस्ट है
बहुत ही ज्यादा बड़ी लिस्ट है अगर पर
एग्जांपल
नहीं है
अगर रूट के देखो तो मिल जाएंगे तो आप किसी
पर्टिकुलर यूजर के बेस पे भी आप कर सकते
हो फाइंड कमांड की हेल्प से यह पता कर
सकते हैं की इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर की के
द्वारा कौन-कौन सी फाइल्स क्रिएट की गई है
आपकी मशीन के अंदर तो यह था
और है
बट हम मुझे लगता की आज इतना ही और करना
चाहिए फाइंड कमांड के बड़े में जानना इतना
काफी आप लोगों के लिए इससे ज्यादा आपको जन
की वजह से जरूर नहीं है अगर मैं बताऊं तो
आप एक चीज और बता देता हूं की अगर आप
फाइंड कमांड में सर्च करना चाहता हूं की
साइज के हिसाब से अगर फाइल का सर्च करना
चाहते हैं कोई फाइंड करना चाहता हूं
फूल रूट के अंदर और साइज ऑफ की जिनका शायद
जितनी फाइल का साइज अगर 50 बी है 50 एमबी
वाली जितनी साइज है वो सर्च करना था की
मेरे जो फूल में उसके अंदर जिंदगी फाइल का
साइज 50 बी है उनको लिस्ट आउट कर दी थी
फाइनल करके बताइए तो ये बता देगा की अभी
अभी परमिशन दे रहा है ओके
पार्टीशन के साथ अभी तक इसको अभी कोई भी
नहीं मिली अगर मैं
10 बी रखना हूं क्या यह मिलेगा
कॉपी
पैलेस आईफोन ल उसके बाद कंट्रोल
कमांड की आपको बहुत हेल्प करने वाली है
खास करके इसका जो एक्स एग्जीक्यूट वाला
एग्जीक्यूशन वाला जो ऑप्शंस है काफी
हेल्पफुल है क्योंकि आप बार-बार क्या
करोगे की पहले फाइनेंस प्रिंट करोगे अपना
आउटपुट में सर्च करोगे उसके बाद क्या की
जितनी फाइल के ऊपर अगर कुछ चेंज कर रहे
होंगे तो वन बाय वन बाय वन बाय चेंज करना
होगा इसकी बजा है आप क्या कर सकते हो
उन सभी फाइल के ऊपर जो भी आप चेंज करना
चाहते हो जिससे क्या हो गया आपका टाइम
बचेगा
तो आपके लिए आई होप की एक बार मुझे बता
दीजिए की सबको आज का सेशन क्लियर है यानी
क्लियर है तो एक बार बता दीजिए चाट में
क्लियर है तो आपके लिए
2 मिनट निकाल दो इतने लोग हैं उनके लिए दो
मिनट काफी है
बता दीजिए
[संगीत]